Kirra visual politic we have talked
about how we now live in a world where
every day there is less poverty and
people are able to live better lives a
change that is even reaching the most
unprotected region in the world
sub-saharan Africa
we already talked about the African
lions and paid special attention to
cases like Rwanda however we still need
to talk about when and why this region
of the world which so many considered
hopelessly destitute began to change
well that is precisely what we are going
to talk about in this video that and
what we can expect in the upcoming years
for years talking about Africa has meant
talking about extreme poverty natural
disasters and all kinds of conflicts and
in a way things are still that way see
no more or less than half yes half of
all the people who suffer from extreme
poverty in the world live in the
sub-saharan African region we're talking
about four hundred million people here
also news like this isn't surprising
either we are facing the largest
humanitarian crisis since the creation
of the United Nations in 1945 now more
than 20 million people across four
countries face starvation and famine
Stephen O'Brien the un
under-secretary-general for Humanitarian
Affairs due to all of this I'm sure
nobody is a stranger to those NGO
campaigns seeking to raise funds for all
kinds of humanitarian catastrophes in
Africa you're probably also familiar
with government's allocating billions of
dollars each year to official
development assistance in fact
government aid is as high as it's ever
been
every year the African continent
receives about fifty billion dollars and
this it's been going on for decades
however the truth is that for years all
of this money it didn't help very much
let's take a look at for example the
1990s
while international aid in this area of
the world amounted to tens of millions
what do you think happens with poverty
do you think it decreased well no none
of that actually
between 1990 and 1998 poverty levels
went from 55% to 58%
well how could this be you might ask
well because intentions are one thing
that reality is really different some
experts claim that for years official
aid weakens local producers evidence
overwhelmingly demonstrates that aid to
Africa has made the poor poorer and
growth slower
dambisa Moyo an economist and the author
of dead aid why Aid is not working and
how there is a better way for Africa for
example in Tanzania is cheap advice
subsidized milk from the European Union
than from local producers however with
the beginning of a new century suddenly
everything began to change
but great change
suddenly when Africa seemed helpless
everything began to change with the
beginning of the 21st century statistics
absolutely turned around since the year
2000 extreme poverty has dropped by
almost 40 percent average life
expectancy has grown by more than 10
years infant mortality has decreased to
less than half the same has happened
with HIV infections in children and well
virtually any other statistics if we
look at the economy we'll be able to see
how between 2000 and 2015 sub-saharan
African countries excluding South Africa
which is a bit of a peculiar case as
we've seen on visual politic previously
grew by an average of 6 percent which is
more than twice for example Latin
America another great indicator of how
things are changing is tourism yep
tourism you heard that right the tourism
sector has some particular
characteristics that reveal a lot of
information on the one hand this sector
has great transformation or power for
the poorest because it's very labor
intensive and on the other hand we need
to take into account so that people
donation in countries that are at war or
a famine or have epidemics it's just not
a nice holiday when this industry
improves in the poorest countries it is
usually a good indicator that things are
improving as a whole well if we see the
data we might be quite surprised because
this sector has been growing at an
average annual rate of no less than 9%
for 20 years that is two full decades of
nearly double-digit growth yes it does
seem as if things are really moving
forward
but at this point in the video you might
be wondering something because I
certainly am what on earth happens to
cause such a change well have a look at
this graph because it really gives a
clue but what exactly led to this
miracle well let's have a look at that
preparing for takeoff many things drive
change but we will now see how three
particular events in Africa began to
change probably permanently this
continents reality the first one it was
remittances see in Africa the population
grows very quickly which along with the
terrible living conditions has led many
Africans to immigrate to richer
countries in the past few decades today
these people send tens of billions of
dollars home every year this money is
used in local markets or to set up
businesses these are what we call
remittances and they are actually much
more important than developmental aid
second and very importantly in March of
2000 the US Congress finally approved a
law that had been promoted by Bill
Clinton in his last years in office it's
called the African growth and
opportunity Act this is basically a law
that establishes a preferential trade
agreements that eliminates tariffs and
reduces barriers to trade for thousands
and thousands of products from
sub-saharan Africa see since this
agreement was approved we can see that
between 2000 and 2016 which weren't
exactly the most prosperous years ever
trade between the United States and
sub-saharan Africa multiplied two and a
half times which means a six percent
growth every year
and thirds and perhaps the key to
everything there's China yep you had it
right in 2001 China it joins the World
Trade Organization and became something
of a factory to the world well what has
happened since then has been quite
impressive China's huge growth has
lifted tens of millions of people out of
poverty both in China and in Africa
government of China enhancing Ethiopia's
industrialization and on supporting the
obvious great vision to become Africa's
manufacturing allow me to explain myself
here the Asian Giants gigantic growth
has increased this country's demand for
all kinds of products raw materials food
manufacturing everything what many
African countries took advantage of this
opportunity since the year 2000 trade
between China and Africa has multiplied
by no less than 17 times representing an
annual growth rate of almost 20% since
2009 China is already by far the
continents largest trading partner
but not only that the Chinese as we
mentioned here have also been investing
a lot of money all over the world and
Africa is certainly no exception in 2016
four out of every ten euros that
foreigners invested in Africa came from
China today more than ten thousand
Chinese companies are doing business on
the African continent mostly private
companies that work in all kinds of
industries and that number well it just
keeps rising yes my friends this is how
Africa has managed to start turning the
statistics around the great catalyst for
this entire change it wasn't some kind
of miracle and it didn't have much to do
with developmental aid this change was
driven by trade and investments and
Africans themselves seem to see it very
clearly if you don't believe me I'll
take a look at this African countries
are forging ahead to complete
negotiations for a continental free
trade area between 55 countries by early
next year the idea adopted by the
African Union in 2012 is to create a
single market which includes the free
movement of goods services and people
yes that's right Africa is working to
expand trade to every corner of the
continent not all countries are
developing equally but this is quite
normal in all parts of the world
following the Asian star
at this point we need to ask ourselves
another question can we really dream of
Africa's final take off see I suspect
that many of you are probably thinking
right now well everything you say in
visual politic is very nice but it isn't
usually what really happens well yes in
Africa it's absolutely true there are
countries that are doing well and there
are countries that are not doing well
but you know what that's true but it's
also really normal see it may sound
shocking today but in the 1950s Asia was
as poor as Africa I mean today we can
look at cities like Shanghai Hong Kong
Taipei it makes it really hard to
imagine that these places were once poor
but when South Korea or Taiwan began to
grow
they weren't richer than Ghana or
Senegal for example and China India and
Vietnam they were of course way poorer
well we can absolutely draw some really
interesting ideas from this because
Asian countries didn't grow all at once
and they didn't grow all together while
Korea Singapore Japan and Taiwan grew
other countries such as China Indonesia
and India remains immersed in poverty
also they weren't exactly Democratic
models South Korea and Taiwan were under
hard dictatorships until very recently
Singapore is in a similar state and
China well what can I say in short lots
of poverty some more advanced countries
with others further behind plenty of
dictatorships essentially what we're
seeing in Africa today wasn't so
different from what was happening in
Asia just fifty years ago
ready for takeoff
yes things in Africa are changing out of
the ten countries that are apparently
growing the most in 2017 five are in
Africa
if we take a look at the latest doing
business report the World Bank indicator
for measuring how easy it is to do
business in certain economies we can see
that out of the ten countries that have
improved the most four are also Africa
true poverty here is still very high in
these countries are facing a difficult
challenge indeed the large population
growth on the continent is actually
going to multiply in the upcoming
decades however dear viewer the good
news is that everything indicates but
thanks to trade and the international
investment Africa is finding its way and
maybe once and for all is ready for take
off but now it's your turn do you think
that Africa will emulate the development
that Asia has had in recent decades well
leave us your answer in the comments
section below as well as in this survey
and I really hope you enjoyed this video
do hit that like button if you did and
do not forget to subscribe for brand new
videos from this channel every Monday
and Thursday also don't forget to check
out our friends of the reconsider media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode but we're not mine and as always
thank you for watching